Scott Disick spotted hanging with Sophia  Ricci again after getting cozy in kanne  France in May the 18 year old model and  the 34 year old reality star have taken  their friendship back to the US the pair  were seen leaving dinner at Nobu in  Malibu Friday night Scott's former flame  Chloe Bartoli was also there this is  fantastic  the trio seemed in great spirits but  Sofia made sure to squash any romance  talk shutting down the rumors for the  second time on Twitter the last time I'm  gonna say it Scott and I are just  friends I'm single and focused on  friends family and work  this comes after Sophia was seen  facetiming the Lord after arriving at  LAX on Thursday do you see other people  at the moment no you don't hmm I mean I  technically could I guess yeah totally  you